all right here we go
time to get cooking in nanny bubby's
kitchen in today's
she's showing us how to prepare muhammad
meze spread
nanny bobby did i say that correctly you
did you said it correctly how are you
look at this beautiful dish that we are
going to make i wanted to show it to you
in the beginning
because it's a bit complicated we may or
may not get to the end
but i want to tell you jc do you realize
that the very last time we worked
together was november of 2019.
oh my gosh why has it been so long i'm
here every friday i've been waiting for
this moment i'm very excited about this
i i think covet is the reason why so do
you see the smoke coming off of these
spices
yes you see what yes so those are cumin
seeds and coriander seeds and the great
thing about this is that when you toast
spices
your nose tells you when they're done i
started them early
so that i would know that they were done
in time and they're done so i'm just
cooling them off a minute
so this mezza spread which muhammad is
a dish that i learned from chef yotam
odolongi
which is a mouthful mohammad and yotam
odalangi is a mouthful
and i wanted to bring this dish exactly
as he taught it in his masterclass
class to all of you so we're going to
start with these
wonderful spices coriander and
cumin and we're going to put them in a
mortal and pestle
which is so fantastic and then
what i love to do is as you're preparing
this we always have the ingredients on
the screen for everyone to write down
what you're doing and
you make everything look so easy when i
see you
i feel like i can get in the cook in the
kitchen and cook and that's what i love
about you
well i love that you say that and so we
started with five bell peppers here
reminding you exactly how to chop bell
pepper so you can get seeds in there
just like that one two three thank you
for that jc
and taking the stem out of the tomato so
this in this platter right here are
five bell peppers one red chili pepper
one white onion and um two
roma tomatoes we're gonna put this into
the oven we're gonna pour a little bit
of garlic um
olive oil salt and pepper i'm hurrying
now because of thyme
and you're gonna wanna get to the end
you just go by feel when you put these
spices in you put a little bit oil in a
little bit saltine
yeah you know the recipe is listed but
really
everything is by sight and uh
smell and feel so into the oven 20
minutes 425 degrees when you're done
put in eight cloves of garlic put it
back in for 20 minutes
giving this to my intern to put in the
chapman oven
and i'm going to show you when it comes
out what it looks like
so there it is all done roasted
and see you see all of this brown this
is caramelization and this is fantastic
so over here are the skins that i took
off i want to just show you how easy it
is to peel off these skins
there we go and and if you get a few
skins in there don't worry about it
we're going to take
all of this and into the food processor
we go
where do you draw your inspiration every
week nanny bobby what do you what what
inspires you every week for these
amazing recipes
i don't know i get really inspired by
things i see and i get
so turned on by it that i can't wait
literally
wait to bring it to you so just to
finish up real quickly
this is the tomato paste which has been
sauteed
in olive oil and caramelized as well
okay just going fast into this also
we're going to just take these
listen jc once you grind and water and
pestle your own spices you will
never ever buy them again brown so
coarsely
from there into there we're going to put
in a
tablespoon and a half of the
pomegranate molasses which is like uh
nectar the gods
and about a half cup of pomegranates
we're going to stick the top on
we're going to coarsely pulse this
don't mix it just pulse it okay one
minute away
we have to then put in toasted walnuts
oh my gosh all the way in are you
getting excited about this
i am this looks delicious because every
week your recipes are amazing are you
kidding me
it tastes better than you think it
really does it is my favorite thing it's
beautiful we're going to plate it really
fast
i'm speeding up here we go i'm going to
get to the end
hopefully you'll see it is gorgeous and
that pomegranate molasses
it makes it so red like hot pink that's
why i love it
and a little bit of pita bread it's so
delicious look at that we're gonna
spread that around oh my gosh there we
go this is healthy too right
this is a healthy dish we're doing well
it is everything is healthy when it
comes from the earth and you don't do
much to it everything is healthy okay
we're gonna drizzle
sorry about that we're gonna drizzle
pomegranate molasses over the top
there we go a little bit of olive oil
because everything glistens better with
olive oil i can't believe we're making
it to the end
we are and parsley and let me tell you
i'm going to grab a spoon and i'm going
to get take a big bite of this
just for you are you ready yes
taste it let's see what we got the world
awaits your reaction
ah perfection perfection
i love it it's all over my face i love
you jason we love you
spread love like butter thank you so
much we appreciate it nanny bobby and
check out nanny bubby's kitchen and
garden on social media
and online at nannybubby.com we also
want to thank chapman automotive
for sponsoring this segment las vegas
now will